oh man bumblebee I can't wait to roll
out to that theater that's what I'm
talking about this was day three pg-13
oh my god I don't even want to see these
movies anymore
another Transformers movie yippee be
quiet child you're worse than Sam
Witwicky shut the fuck up you know what
shut the fuck up me you guys only got
five movies that ain't nothing son of a
bitch Transformers the last night also
known as transformers 5 is directed once
again by Michael Bay and stars Mark
Wahlberg again and Anthony Hopkins and
some other people and according to most
of the trailers this one has Optimus
Prime going evil searching for something
on earth and going against all of his
friends and fighting bumblebee and the
humans have to scatter and try to figure
out how to survive and hopefully save
their planet from an impending doom
again again again again
let's start with the good news every
single movie in the Transformers
franchise since the first one got
progressively longer age of extinction
which I still think is the worst in the
franchise was 2 hours and 45 minutes
long this one is actually the shortest
since the first according to IMDB it's
about 2 hours and 29 minutes so that's
nice also I do think this movie is an
improvement over the last one that being
said the last one was complete garbage
so it's not like that was too hard they
somewhat dialed down the heuristically
aggressive product placement we still
get a hilarious shot of Mark Wahlberg
drinking a Bud Light in this one though
just like in the last one your court Oh
yep we're into the bad now the last
night is probably exactly what you
thought it was going to be if you've
ever seen a Transformers movie a giant
bloated extravaganza with a whole bunch
of side characters and extra subplots
that don't have to be there
cringe-worthy humor that thinks it's
hilarious what's really not racial
stereotypes young kids who curse a lot
because kids who curse are cool a very
famous actor who doesn't mind appearing
in a film that they may not have much
passion for but the older demographic
will love to see a female character with
a very specific bone structure and look
and a hero who's just a normal human but
he does superhero stuff and a bunch of
military subplots
and people walking fast through always
can't forget that I didn't hate the last
night I hated the age of extinction that
movie was boring long and filled with
just stupid idiotic shit for almost the
entire runtime this movie actually has
some entertaining sequences the finale
is fun it's cool to look at there are
some moments of genuine entertainment in
the last night and I am not someone
who's a Michael Bay hater
I've liked some of his movies before the
island the rock first transformers even
dark of the Moon I think is okay
that was hard to say I can go to a
Michael Bay movie and enjoy watching his
command over giant productions he's
clearly very good at that but in the end
these movies are basically all the same
there's nothing new or fresh here to
change the series and make it go in a
different direction we're in the fifth
one by the time the Fast and the Furious
movies got to the fifth one they finally
understood that to make them good they
had to change it up I didn't like a
single Fast and Furious movie until Fast
Five because that was the first one that
seemed like they were actually trying to
make a fun and entertaining movie that
was more than just car racing or take
ghost Protocol for instance that was
such a fast-paced and exciting movie
that was so much different from the
other ones that it really revitalized
the franchise that's what the
Transformers series needs some fresh
blood some revitalization some different
viewpoints of these characters that
would be amazing because essentially
we're getting the exact same movies over
and over again and what scares me the
most is that people keep paying to see
him and we're just going to keep getting
them again and again and again and again
if we keep paying to see him but just
like I said with this entire franchise
since the first one every single one of
these movies just has so many needless
subplots and extra characters there's
one character they keep cutting back to
in this movie who's obsessed with saying
that everyone else is wrong and he's
right he's in front of all these
military people trying to convince them
that they have to pay attention to what
he has to say to save the planet I don't
understand why no one's listening to me
you guys have to understand physics and
math don't rely on these robots to save
the earth you have to listen to me okay
you're welcome thank you you're welcome
if you enjoy characters like that in
your action movies well have fun with
the last night because you're going to
get a lot of stuff like that Mark
Wahlberg is Mark Wahlberg he's
entertaining he's likable he's handsome
he's got muscles he can carry a movie I
mean he does his job but he's far better
than this and he's proved that in movies
like The Departed he has a lot of talent
and I would like to see him do more
stuff like that and less of this kind of
thing Anthony Hopkins is Anthony Hopkins
you can watch him in a movie and be like
wow he's he's awesome he's Anthony
Hopkins and that's kind of what I'm
getting at here
this movie feels like a bunch of
financial decisions Mark Wahlberg people
like Mark Wahlberg will put him in the
movie oh thanks guys
I got to wear the stupid haircut like a
year damn man guys come on take an
interest in science and I already said
earlier how all the films have those
little boxes checked off for each
demographic to be happy and of course
all the advertisement which this one
doesn't have as much of as the others I
don't think but it's still there I mean
there's actually a shot where Wahlberg
has like a robot specifically made to
bring him a Bud Light so he can drink it
like I said there are some entertaining
moments it has less cringe-worthy humor
than the fourth and especially the
second but in the end it's more of the
same I'm going to give Transformers the
last night a c-minus guys thank you so
much as always for watching I just want
to say I hit 1 million subs I am so
grateful thank you so much for always
sticking with me and watching my reviews
I am so so thankful to be able to talk
about movies with you guys you're very
passionate and I share that passion
about film with you it means the world
to me that you have stuck with me this
long and I haven't forgotten my promise
I will very soon review my
feature-length movie I made when I was
16 years old that's going to be fun I
can't wait to talk about that and I'll
show you guys clips and stuff and I'll
make fun of it and we'll have a great
time thank you once again as always for
watching it if you like this you can
click right here and get to stuff my
knives
[Music]